[Music]
he was afraid he'd sob while he
terminated their jobs but was the ceo a
buffoon for firing them all via zoom
vishal garg
yes that vishal garg
i was wondering where he was
but a long time since i heard from
vishal garg
the ceo of the online mortgage lender
better.com well that sounds up and up
fired nearly 900 employees during a
recent zoom call
the reason for the surprise downsize
well in addition to changing market
conditions yes of course apparently
workers were being unproductive and that
was tantamount to stealing from
customers i would have been outraged too
if i knew what tantamount means is that
really necessary the word tantamount for
the holiday season it should be santa
mount
according to garg
so it's so garg of him to do this though
i have to tell you the company started
taking a closer look at employee
productivity metrics and that's when
they noticed the lack of performance but
the ceo says the decision to fire so
many it wasn't an easy one
this is the second time in my career i'm
doing this and i do not do not want to
do this the last time i did it i cried
we are laying off about 15
of the company if you're on this call
you are
part of the unlucky group being laid off
it's terrible brutal that takes some
serious stones to expect sympathy from
the people he just fired he's gonna make
him cry
but i guess he is the real victim i mean
he still has to work for
that's him emily
anyhow here's how my cat fired his last
assistant
you know i learned as when i was i've
aspired three times in my uh career in
publishing sometimes you need a little
push
you need somebody to push you out the
door sometimes firings could be really
good emily but uh was this the most
practical way to fire people on zoom i
love it really one you're a terrible
person i am a great person you love that
cuomo got fired and now you're dancing
on these people my true colors are
coming out they are they're all black
you're a dark person i am here's why so
first of all i love that these guys on
average were clocking eight hours a day
and yet their productivity was two hours
a day these are like 900 employees they
are stealing your money and yet this guy
had the garg had the reputation for
um high expectations and getting upset
over tiny infractions this isn't a tiny
infraction this is straight up theft
when i was a federal attorney i was a
managing one so i was in charge of
firing right and when i fired people
first of all everyone lost their mind it
would freak out i would have to notify
security ahead of time i would have to
have all these things in between me and
the person and like a letter opener in
my bun in case i had to defend myself so
this guy doing it over zoom i'm like
absolutely wipe the slate clean your
safety's insured and get these guys out
of there because they're probably all
generation z or millenniums millennials
who don't know the value of time and
hard work why am i the only person
saying that i don't know what to do
i feel so strongly about this you'll be
seen on tick tock lately
chat um i love the fact that it's called
better.com that's uh slightly ironic
yeah it's like better than what exactly
uh well this guy look this guy's okay
like
i did
i did some research on him and it sounds
seems like he's a bad guy you know he's
got a reputation for being a
but
when i was fired from my traffic
reporting job they made me drive to fire
me
which i would have rather been fired
over zoom because it's like i had to
spend money on gas for you to tell me
you'll no longer be paying for my gas
would you not have done it over the
phone so i feel like that's nice and
also how do you fire 900 people
individually mm-hmm
that's a lot of people it's a lot of
work efficient uh ari you've probably
fired more than a few people in your
time what do you how do you grade this
well first and foremost the good news is
there are now 900 openings for chris
cuomo there you go so he's got a future
potentially
um
but be careful when you use the word
openings
different sector story yes that's for
the debate stay tuned right
between cat and emily i'm leaning
toward emily really i think emily's on
to something here look the source of the
information about people were clocking
in for eight hours but only working for
two because when you work from home and
you work from zoom you've got a lot of
freedom don't you
the source of it was the guy who did all
the firing the ceo of the company
previously anonymously and he shouldn't
have done it anonymously should have put
his name on it sent an email to all the
employees complaining about that fact
that he did a search the data shows you
guys aren't logging in you're missing
meetings with clients you're not showing
up for customer appointments blame covey
well they were taking advantage of yeah
right yeah i mean there is something
going on in society now where it's good
to have people working from home i like
working from home but it's are you
really working it's it's a path of
resistance like when you can get away
with something easily you tend to get
away with it's like we have all this
free free damn food in this company
because to keep us from going out during
clothing all i do is i eat packaged
snacks i put up 10 pounds because it's
easy you're fired
i'm fired up to talk to dr drew
i'm afraid i'm gonna have to let you go
forward with an interesting comment um
dr drew i want to focus on the thing
that
actually
ari's kind of
convinced me that maybe the crazy mean
lady's right
but
that's you
emily a nutcat
yeah it's crazy nice he told his former
business partner that he was going to
quote staple him against the wall and
burn him alive
i'm just saying probably not a nice guy
all right
that is uh that's good evidence this is
like a real court case dr drew yeah um i
love the part that he was telling people
how hard it is for him and that it would
make him cry is that a good strategy no
no
it's like this is so hard for me you're
losing your job yes yeah it's not good
but it's interesting that now employers
have to realize that disgruntled
employees have a whole new set of ways
to get really revenge right put it bring
a camera in tape whatever you're doing
put it on tock here we go and
disgruntled employees as you know you
have to you that's why you wear that
thing in your hair i didn't know that in
case she has to shiv somebody it can get
to be a problem i had to do this once i
had a web company back in the day and we
had to fire like half our company which
was a 75 people yeah you had to bring
them all into a room and go
uh worst thing i ever have to do i'm
available for as long as you need to
talk about it that's what he should have
done i would if that if you did i would
have been calling you up on love line
heckling you when you used to do that
show you still do that show no i don't
you used to heckle me no i would you
would i would that's what i would do to
get back at you you know what drives me
crazy and then i'll leave it there why
is everybody in the tech industry
wearing sleeveless down vests like even
when you're firing people do you have to
wear the sleeveless vest it's that
everybody look everybody's wearing this
you see this on these
like oh they're in davos or they're in
aspen they're all wearing this you're
firing people why don't you wear a gd
tie for god's sake with your sleeveless
thank you all right